if you're saying okay most men so like
men that are on dating apps let's say
they're between like what 25 and 45 or
like in their mid-30s like swiping on 18
year olds that girl doesn't have she has
no no
wait wait wait I think I think okay okay
but but the point that's not the point
I'm making the point is that men are
attracted to Youth and Purity and the
problem is and and Beauty right and like
thin thinner women or curvy you know you
know slump that you know and so like the
point is there's a million women that
are pretty and Youthful there's a new
girl turning who doesn't have to be 18
let's give 22 every day okay and feel
more comfortable yeah we can there's
some studies that have said 21 22 I'm
just giving you one that kind of shows
the extreme and so the the point I'm
making is there's a lot of women that
want the top one percent of men and like
that's why most women are going to be
single and childless is because we all
want the same guys
we want a guy that makes money we also
want to be attracted to him we also
don't want him to cheat on us and it's
like I mean I understand that but I
think another part of that is just like
women are like are which I mean the
other side to that coin is like why are
women's standards so high because we've
seen what happens again like being
children of like we've seen how bad it
can be when you don't have high
standards like we've seen so like again
I I understand like when we talk about
like quality of life what about the men
I mean all these men I mean you're also
like that's the thing that's in the back
of my mind you're like oh all these
women are childless and well then also
there's a large percentage of men that
are awesome so like there's who are
these women potentially going to marry
like there's like not so I mean that's
also another side to that and I I don't
I can't like I don't have the statistics
you're the computer in front of you I
don't but I remember like having
conversation with someone about this
actually on a date um and he told me
that like men between the ages of like
single men between the ages of like 32
and like 45 who are singing are more or
like a specific demographic of men that
are most most likely unfortunately to
like analyte themselves so whereas women
are not like as likely you're you're
actually you're correct like most of
throughout most of History men have not
reproduced only 40 of men have
reproduced historically but that's
that's always been the way where 80 of
women have reproduced historically or 90
80 to 90 depends on who you look at so
it's odd now that 50 of women will not
reproduce and and now and you said what
will that mean for relationships moving
forward as women raise and raise their
standards it just means we're sharing
guys how do relationships no think about
it I mean you've probably been a side
chick at some point do you how do how do
you really no no I know this is this is
crazy but I'm gonna explain it okay how
do relationships start sex or or a
relationship what usually comes first
sex What in in 2022 I mean relationship
for me okay so every person you've ever
slept with the relationship came first
the fine relationship like we got to not
not it so so usually like the
situationship like this is you're my
boyfriend a boyfriend girlfriend I would
say it's like 50 50. okay so so in the
situationships typically that's a man
you find attractive right yeah yeah so
that means other women find them
attractive so you're probably not the
only one he's sleeping with so you kind
of start as a side chick and if you if
you do good you might get promoted to
girlfriend
yeah in a way yeah because the number
one way people are meeting nowaday are
dating apps online and and again women
only swipe right five percent of the
time what does that mean we're sharing
if you're on a date if you're on a date
with a guy I mean but we're all but like
the inverse is also true like we're also
women are also being courted by multiple
men at the same time so again like I I'm
struggling to that's that's true but of
what percentage so it's like 80 percent
of women want 20 of men that's actually
100 but 80 of women share 20 of men I
don't like this word share no I don't
you don't like it but it's true Did you
you had a question green so yeah I was
going back to the what you were saying
before like what standard is it you
expect or you're insinuating that women
should have done that because I don't
think you have to settle yeah but I
don't think he's wrong to say I don't
want a man that doesn't I don't want a
man who cheats I want a man who earns a
certain amount of money that's
you know realistics or whatever standard
that woman is at and obviously just a
good Rel I just don't see what is wrong
with that expectation okay so I don't
think it's wrong to want a man that does
enjoy again again I again I was raised
by a dad that never cheated he had 10
kids he was a multi-millionaire he he
had a lot of yeah he was nine siblings
we have nine siblings yeah yeah I mean
yeah it's nice
what number are you um four four but
they adopt it it's a long story they
adopted some like later but it's okay
but but
I don't think it's wrong to want that
but the problem is if you're going to go
for a guy if you want him to be handsome
not just like uh okay handsome
attractive right but remember women so
um women rate 80 and it's okay you guys
have never heard this stuff before I
don't expect you to know it but women
rate 80 percent of men is unattractive
okay but how many times have you heard a
girlfriend like oh but he's cute to me
like how many times have you heard women
like we we are historically like women
lower our standards for men so much so
much more likely to do that right but
but so no no but remember remember women
rate 80 of men is unattractive so so top
20 of men 10 women might be like oh he's
hot the next 10 oh he's okay
okay which is which is which is fine
you're less likely to get cheated on if
you date a less attractive guy that's
not true okay okay guys but this is look
guys guys guys again you don't think
okay you don't think good guy with
character would have a hard time saying
no to a model okay so listen right
sometimes when you date an unattractive
guy the second that somebody else starts
giving him attention he's like oh two
people are giving me attention at the
same time oh I I've never he's not
unattractive
two girls two girls are giving him
attention no okay I've given attention
because his man's like his sexual what
is it his sexual rating goes higher
depending on the woman that he has on
his arms
he could be this he could be a two but
he's with an eight he's immediately a
six but usually when girls say this
they're not ugly guy like if you could
show me him and I won't show it on
screen but if you show me the picture no
usually because I've done this on the
show it's always guys that I would rank
a six or seven and typically like girls
will say oh I'm dating medium ugly it's
not medium ugly that's just your level
respectfully like and I've been there
I've been there but like
but but it's it's just honest and so
it's like women want everything and even
like because also want everything no
they that's that's so again when the men
swipe right 50 what men swipe right like
the data just doesn't indicate that
because men find about half of women
attractive like it's actually crazy when
I started talking to men there'd be a
girl that I think is like kind of chunky
or like unattractive and I'm like would
you would you smash and they're like
hell yeah and finding whether or not
someone would like sleep with someone
does not mean that like he'll like go
take her out on dates does not mean
he'll take her home there's nothing
which is which is fine which is fine but
remember it in 2022 it starts with
situationships typically so that's where
it starts I can't get behind this
because then earlier you were saying oh
men value Purity value so like and now
you're saying oh it starts with sex like
I I can't get behind this yeah yeah okay
okay yeah men do value Purity and they
like having sex
I'm just saying that like it's just not
adding up for me like the argument that
you're making oh I don't know it's not
an argument it just is what it is it's
like okay men will want to sleep with a
bunch of girls typically like if they
could do it the way they wanted to if
you know if they had a Bus full of
models waiting to sleep with them
they're probably going to do it but they
want to wife a girl and make the main
share the girlfriend a girl that hasn't
been with a lot of people
yeah kind of can I just say something
real quick it's just like like I said
before I'm pretty sure I mentioned as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible